South Hartford 911 quelle est votre
urgence
madame quel est le problème quand j'avais
environ 8 ans ma mère a assassiné
trois personnes ont fait la montée dans la maison
avaient commis ces meurtres lors d'un
exorcisme un exorcisme pratiqué sur elle
la Sainte Église s'est impliquée elle était
transféré à l'hôpital psychiatrique Centrino
à Rome, alors me voilà, il a commencé à
se demander si c'était dans mon adolescence, est-ce que je vais
m'effondrer un jour, c'est des précautions, elle
est devenue si difficile qu'il y a un
bouton de panique sur le mur ouais je suis ta
fille
connecte les coupures
si vous voulez vraiment aider votre mère,
vous avez besoin d'une meilleure compréhension de l'
exorcisme que suggérez-vous que vous ayez besoin d'en
voir un
vrai c'est une combinaison de science et de
religion basée sur mes antécédents en
médecine mademoiselle Pina
ouais elle a dit mon nom a trouvé quatre voix
sur les enregistrements, qu'est-ce que cela signifie
possession démoniaque multiple, s'il vous plaît, aidez
ma mère,
cela ne correspond à aucune forme de
possession que j'ai jamais vue, je suis désolé
Isabella